y si será el jugador del país así lo
anuncia el diario deportivo francés
l'equipe si esta información exacta el
avión de este seis veces van gundy oro
llegará esta tarde interés de bella
pasar el examen médico justo después
llegó a firmar su contrato en contrato
de 12 años con la posibilidad de un
tercer años
desde este anuncio el número de
seguidores del pago son demasiado
aplicado ligeramente frente al back de
los principios donde estoy porque es
aquí que messi debería venir para la
firma de su contrato a mi lado puedes
ver algunos gritos de alegría sobre todo
y esperanza de los seguidores que llevan
tres días esperando esta llegada
mientras la felicidad de los aficionados
del club de parís ya no el este
barcelona el club que me dijo durante
más de 20 años la preocupación es cada
vez más mayor este fin de contrato puede
ser una pérdida de 60 y 37 millones de
oro una disminución de sus ingresos
comerciales y eso a pesar que el club
llegan varios años con una dificultad
financiera pero de momento aquí en
parecerá una felicidad porque la
posibilidad de haber vencido
que ha estado tan cerca